hi everybody welcome to the first
episode of pitch garyvee a new series
that kind of came out of the birth of
all the hip-hop video and meetings we've
had but now what I realize is I'm taking
a lot of meetings so not a lot these
days but I did forever and I kind of
want to get back into it where startups
are pitching me I figured you know what
why don't we film these things
why don't we filmed these things for two
reasons one so many of you are trying to
figure out how to pitch to good VCS and
angel investors and I had that kind of
career so I'm gonna ask those kind of
questions number two very honestly for
the startups that are able to get
through the filter Anto filter who is
the Mike Boyd of this series fill my
right hand for last decade admin all the
way to the my right hand and investing
for the people that are able to get
through his filter that Union you'll see
in this episode how many meetings a year
he's taking it's great exposure maybe I
won't invest but maybe you will and so
I'm really excited to put people on
whether they're hip-hop artists whether
they're startups and I'm also really
excited to put many people on that are
trying to learn how to pitch and have
the cadence and I just have a funny
feeling this is the beginning of a very
exciting series in my content life hi
hello Rachel how are you guys good how
are you sit thank you how are things
funded also I forgot my notebook
that's my so what's cooking
so Rachel neha started a company called
the Clos bar we have never filmed a
pitch start to finish before we have it
and I thought that they would be the
great first candidates because I love
their passion of their story and I loved
the concept I also wanted to get them in
front of you
what's a glowing word of you Phil sees a
lot of [ __ ] I know they lucky we
remember in our when we first met with
you when you were like eyes like real
like you did really well just now and
Neha and I like acted cool I think at
the time
[ __ ] office we were like no ideas do
you think you've seen the last year for
concerts
probably Holi between a thousand and
throw my gosh Wow bless me men you know
prep ourselves yeah where you from I'm
from Boston
am i what a patriot scram I don't know
what really that was good yeah Fort
Lauderdale Florida the good life we can
tell you like more about ourselves if
that would be helpful I'm not very sure
about that yeah we do - or real people
people I've been in beauty for ten years
I started at Birchbox they love their
investment those friends of ours so I
wrote the first check into Birchbox
right and so that was six or seven years
ago and I remember that meeting like it
was yesterday we were in Starbucks in
Midtown and they were pitching and they
probably got about 60 words in and I
said I was in and I remember them
getting super pumped and emotional and
nothing you know like pretty emotional
and I remember just was like what's like
cool awesome like I was palm - but I was
like you know like and they were just
like we've gotten so many knows you know
like we needed this yes and I was like
cool like I've seen that before
like I didn't think much of it and it
was super interesting it's probably
around this time of year it was that
first really nice day in New York City
after like the winter you know like that
perfect like I don't know if it was
April or May but it was that day I think
we all know what they that was and I was
ironically less busy back then so I
could actually walk home and I live in
the Upper East Side in that 30 block
walk I remember somewhere around halfway
being like wait a minute like is it
possible like the business was so
obvious to me it was like we're gonna
get samples and sell them I was like
that's a great [ __ ] business
his journey glow bar and I was there for
four years let our partnerships team so
really like pitching brands and we mean
that one meeting I came in when I was in
that conference room with jab jab hook
it's so funny you walk them like god
this [ __ ] yes I definitely yeah I was
thinking of bringing the book to get you
to sign up funny when he walks oh my god
I'm like we have like Whedon like I
really that's super cool I remember that
meeting very well yeah and that was a
really cool thing we did we had every
month like yep not just common like talk
to us and like teach us what worked for
them what didn't like any advice and I
remember it was like our best like
team-building saying that they ever did
so I was there for four years left I
learned like the startup space and like
the venture back space but really wanted
to learn how they kind of found it like
a soul foot pride or owned a business
know and ran a business and how it was
it all operated so into beautyblender
the world's number one makeup sponge and
worked there for the past three and a
half years and really realized I wanted
to do my own thing and then neha and i
found one another i we manifested one
another you know she can tell you a bit
about herself
so i previously was a management
consultant at bain and company spent a
lot of time there consumer and retail
practices and got really obsessed with
thinking about the consumer when you're
a management consultant i wasn't really
able to kind of get into that side of
the business so then i ex turned for a
henry davis the CEO of glossier ahead of
their series c so just thinking about
like different strategic initiatives
that they were had top of mind at the
time and really understanding how a
company that focuses on consumer is
actually doing that operationally and
like what they're winning this place
which was really really cool insight to
get coming out of that I was like okay I
kind of wanna I want to do I want to try
this I want to put this to practice
send that to a colleague Rachel and also
said that to a colleague and like Holly
was like you two should meet
no way yeah yeah and we're like I mean
you he's not like a statue of this
person in the office her name is Alyssa
Alyssa she's an amazing marketer
actually and she like just saw like I
think that we were completely different
people but cuz like
together and really build something
amazing yeah you guys are gonna have to
have like like we have to make a shrine
for her we're working on actually should
do more for her I know
we thanked her anchors to like like
Easter eggs within your business yeah um
so yeah so what's the business we don't
like her so at the end of the day what
we're really trying to do is help people
take better care of their skin and we
want to do that a in person and also be
online so as we think about it in person
it's really seeing an expert for her and
providing skin care treatments because
we think she needs to be seeing someone
professional at least once a month to
take better care of her skin to really
make her at home routine work and be
more effective and what are most women
doing now yeah so most women are taking
care of their skin at home yep and trial
and error it's a complete [ __ ] show Gary
yeah everyone's buying stuff at Sephora
they're looking at on YouTube for like
tutorials of how to do a mask or how to
use a product and then they're going to
their dermatologist once a year or twice
the year which once or twice a year once
a year and what's a facial a face being
serious is it out yeah I know what it is
you're like but like what is it in the
practice of this yeah so a facial is
about an hour and a half appointment as
it stands today and it's about 12 steps
yeah
they wash your face at nauseam they
massage about their that I've done -
they do they like foggy Stevie you're
like sweating down your neck right okay
she's like down your ears and you're
like you and they're like see you in ten
minutes and then they come back and it
takes forever and so the consumer opts
out they're not taking care of their
skin because it takes too long it's
expensive it's $150 on average and they
don't know who to trust and so they're
so is that where you're disrupting yeah
exactly so be faster better priced more
contemporary yep effective 30-minute
treatment only only yeah max or min - 30
30
Mary's one offering how many places do
this how many do you have locations we
are opening our first in - good for you
we're Tribeca good okay we're excited
I'm the 30 minutes only 30 mm what have
you been doing so far like visiting
people
so we we are just getting started and so
what we've been doing is figuring out
what happens in those 30 minutes so
we've been testing all the protocols
they want to do how we want to do them
and also how we want to like has this
been like on friends and family or like
people just coming over like you're
doing them yeah so we actually have a
partnership with an aesthetic school
outside of Boston that my grandmother
started that's great yeah so it's a
legacy it's really like if you ask me
why I'm doing this like not only am i
hungry and just like [ __ ] want my own
business but like really like my
grandmother pioneered skincare and I
really want to modernize it honest and
your grandmother pioneering skincare
like super documented like in like
Google searches like you could look is
that like well I've rented it a sec
school in the country she live yeah she
is that's amazing yeah she doesn't she
has dementia so she doesn't really know
what's going on but a great one does to
it yeah and it's like but sometimes when
my mom would be like rachel is opening a
salon because it's like the best way to
just get it to her brain should be like
so we have a partnership with our
aesthetics law and that's where we
really consider that to be like our RN
do you like the perks and we go there
and leave not only had like focus groups
with the estheticians there but also
done all of our protocols and tested
there three times now so yeah we have
like proof of our protocols keep going
yeah so what's happening online so in
terms of online there's obviously
consumers are really looking at their
phones a lot and other computers a lot
and so when we think about educating her
more in the space and telling her about
what treatment did you just receive why
did you receive that what should you do
at home what you do not do at home we
want to have those communications online
and so we're starting with follow-up
emails right after that like kind of
tell her everything that happened during
that treatment and we're able to do that
because we're putting tech in place in
our studios that is gonna be recording
all of this data that's happening during
the treatment and then communicating
that back to her understood and why
that's really important to the process
is that no one's doing that today and I
give you a huge piece of advice yeah
that's what we're here for
I really think that you need to do
that content in multiple forms
predicated on how she wants to consume
it your ability to transcribe that
information into boys or even long-term
eventually transcribe it visually is
something you should give a lot of
thought to the amount of companies that
have failed or have struggled to get the
traction they wanted because they've
predicated on a singular form of written
communication that doesn't map to her
life if I would never read that email
I don't read emails up clients giving me
three million dollars yeah so I have
like full-time at like like so I think
we're not a big investment a
disproportionate leverage point tip for
you could be that subtle form of
communication like before you start even
going down the path its pattern
recognition it's you know I know where
you're what you're about to say you're
gonna be you're gonna have to bridge to
that yeah you're probably you're
probably not gonna raise the height of
capital it's gonna allow you to have six
seven full time like you know yeah so I
do think I do think that subtle
communication in the beginning is a much
much bigger deal than people realize
yeah yeah and it's not being done at all
today so I think that the consumer like
the loop with the consumer like if we
got her into our space give her an
amazing experience and then connect with
her after and get her back in that's
where we really gonna retain her and get
that lifetime work and no one is doing
that today it's like the conversation
starts in the salon and then it stops
because they don't do any follow up also
to a very small group of individuals
right right like if it's an hour and a
half and like right it's expensive you
think about high net worth women right
now you know this is not X you know I
don't know how many hundred fifty dollar
pay shows about you know facials are
happening in places that are more
middle-class or right you know yeah so
we're definitely targeting we're
targeting the thirty to forty five year
old woman also which is like a big white
space and beauty people are all talking
to the Millennial a great only really
web up here well yeah right yeah yeah
nobody agrees more than me and by the
way that's the only email subscription
that I still subscribe to as a 33 year
old woman any look I love pure and
former neighbor O'Brien
would I love it yeah that's probably why
you're still okay why not just because
of okay um so yeah we're targeting that
like thirty to forty five year old woman
and we really believe like we're gonna
be finding her on Instagram and on
Facebook obviously but even more
importantly we really believe in earned
media and I think that's important to
say because our experience is our
marketing we don't have a marketing
budget of like a million dollars to
start with raising only a million
dollars yes um and so we really need to
make sure like that puts the onus on
Neha and I to build like a kick-ass
experience for her so that she comes in
loves it and then talks about it that's
what we're gonna win yeah it's like
organic growth at the beginning and
grassroots and some other exciting
initiatives that we have plans that we
think are pretty scrappy and fun clever
and clever yes that's one of our brand
tenants but uh eventually we will get
into likes and paid so so it's literally
physical you're like the digital part it
you do think like there's a like do you
think there's a rep there's a revenue
stream on the Digital side or is it a
retention thing
so to start it'll be primarily retention
yeah so that physical experience sure
brick-and-mortar is like really our
Channel yes our over time five years
from now when the landscape really
starts changing is when the digital
landscape becomes more of a revenue
stream and we think of how you actually
make her digital number and how do you
engage the girl who's when you say the
landscape changes over five years
you think the technology advances that
allow the tella work to be really
meaningful because just the clarity of
like being able to analyze the skin
through a mobile device or the landscape
of your business just growing to a scale
where that can become meaningful yeah I
think it's one of the two so I think in
right now to have it doesn't even exist
for her to come once a month and so to
form that how that we need those
physical spaces but as that habit is
formed and as people become more
comfortable with talking test petitions
they don't really need that physical you
know one thing I love about you guys is
how little money you're taking like
because that's my dream but one thing
that does run still this is a more of
course because it means not smart I
everyone just cares about banking it's
Sam it's everybody cares about like
everybody says that because the economy
has been flourishing for a decade and
there's so much money in the system you
know we've had more investors past
because we aren't accepting enough money
then giving us money it's a wild
experience it's like you're expecting to
by the way Joey it's also a very clever
way that B sees like to say pass yeah
what you'll what I will say is you have
a capital intensive business if you're
gonna go physical location rollout right
yeah
Tribeca rent isn't cheap so not yes so
there's there's too full to that one is
we've really adjusted our real estate
strategy for that so rather than
building the big flagships we actually
asked ourselves well how small can we
make this work without compromising some
extremes yeah and what we've done is
lowered our build-out cost and rents
relative to others in the space beyond
that the payback period is actually
pretty quick for this kind of business
especially cuz the margins are pretty
good and so it actually gives us a bit
of runway so if I've let down 200k to
build out a space within six to eight
months we've made that back right and so
that kind of helps our initial
investment into going into this brick
and mortar listen I respect that I'm you
know like I built an e-commerce wine
business on top of a brick and mortar
store which allowed me to do it right so
I understand that so you feel like
you've been able to not compromise
expiry you know cuz what how much you
gonna do it for how much is the price
point I said that ninety seventy and so
you're saying pretty hardcore facials in
the city are a buck fifty floor for an
hour and a half is that right yeah or or
average an asset floor so do you believe
that one thing that runs through my mind
do you believe that if if the woman is
thinking okay I'm paying a buck fifty
about twenty a buck seventy for an hour
and a half that's seventy four thirty do
you think some people are basic and
they're just thinking [ __ ] it's actually
amortized out two to ten is your big
comms challenge gonna be that you're
gonna get the results you need and so
we're not because you just made me
comment gal and I'll just say cargo but
just human human oh you're
Premium yeah because you're 210 right
yeah I think one thing that you'll have
a real challenge of is is and it's a
good challenge but back to like your
clever marketing stunts yeah I highly
recommend that for the four dollars you
do have allocated for comms and things
that nature we talked about you better
yeah cause if you're dating partner are
you better yeah we have to talk about
how although we have a lower price point
in a lower amount of time we've taken
out all the fiber such a big idea Todd
talk to us I think time is the number
one valuable thing on earth yeah I think
that you should do as much clever [ __ ]
as possible
in telling these women what the average
woman can do with an extra hour a day
wait I have a list of this and I have a
list of everything you can do in 30
minutes Crest Whitestrips an episode of
friends and all that and then what you
can do if you save yourself an hour you
should you should lean into the hour
yeah the half an hour like this is just
psychology consumed by the way you
should do both but my intuition is that
the hour is like if you do a whole
campaign of what would you do with an
extra hour yeah and then basically just
[ __ ] on the industry for wasting an hour
like we're not women that have nothing
to do yeah that's empowering on trend
like [ __ ] you establishment we have [ __ ]
to do have a little bit of a negative
connotation listen I think that to your
point like this is one point of view and
one tone of the execution yeah my
intuition and what my thesis is is you
do a bunch of them okay like like one of
them could be like you can do something
nice for your mother-in-law that it
sounds like you're wonderful right one
one could listen I do think it's always
smart to be like [ __ ] the man like you
made us waste an hour I don't think it
plays especially for cheeky and not as
serious to your point okay I think that
you should you're always one comp
interview one clever Instagram post away
I do think it's a very powerful pillar
to play
okay I believe in voice strictly on the
time savings I believe I finally
understood uber when I understood they
were selling time you know like time
Amazon's wedding is a time yeah yeah
time so just just uh just the sheer
amount of like really deeply leaning
into like a flood like who's got an hour
to waste no one no one especially the
demo that we're targeting correct yeah
we were actually just we had someone
asked us like if you guys are doing
something that's very effective and
you're doing it in an efficient way you
just have to ask yourselves as a
consumer value efficiency and reason I
really write more than just wonder said
that to you went to cliche like Oh women
love to be pampered like sure so many
times a year when you have a [ __ ]
hour thank you yeah you're preaching
yeah
like they're crazy less because they
have a problem they want solved and they
need help and I do this and what I think
is better than blowing out your hair is
that you're talking about something very
macro right so the thing I like about it
is it's it's mmm its mmm not more
dentist than blowing out your hair but
it's definitely more in between them
like right you're just amazing yeah I
think you're in between we're in between
like a derma pointment and a traditional
spa because we're solutions oriented
which is what the consumer wants and
what do you think how often do you think
they should like everyone's every
woman's skin is different
I get it monthly monthly it once a month
really what we talk about a lot is like
you don't really shell will you sell
have you thought about selling yearly
subscription then every box is in my
core get it so you would is there a
better deal than 840 for a year mm-hm
you want you look like 15% 10 to 15%
it's like the industry norm yeah and
you'll get a percentage off retail
product that we sell and the difference
between us and like others is that we're
really partnering with professional
brands which ups our credibility we're
not partnering with those that you can
find at Sephora blue mercury because
well Nevada brand type stuff that whole
dermo brand that bad fashion all
professional that are only sold through
the esthetician which really elevates
our recitations because we actually care
just as much about the client
as our estheticians our labor force is
what our business is built on you should
care more about this listen you're
actually paying them like 25 percent
more than the industry average in the
city we're hoping to like build a career
oriented labor model have you thought
about building their brands even though
that creates a vulnerability for you
building the brands that were working
with nobody estheticians oh we thought a
lot about that how can I give you a huge
piece of advice yeah you should
disproportionally try to make them
famous so we talk a lot about how there
are movie stars
you should just proportionally try to
make them famous the number one mistakes
that all these companies are making
right now in exercise and everything
else yeah is they're scared to let them
build their brands because then they
have leverage and then they leave then
they don't all these of course not
and more poorly right if you're known
for building brands they'll all come to
you right right yeah you'll have a
pipeline greater than the people that
leave that's so smart yeah like you
should almost literally build an
internal agency of personal brands for
these people it will become a singular
point of leverage for you and your
industry yeah I think we're committed to
that for sure
we're really excited about hiring r-type
I would really really can't stress it
enough okay toppled here yeah ii you
with fifty nine goddamn Instagram
followers but with press cuz you've
launched show post three this is Karen
here's her story we love her every other
industry professional looks at them be
like my place will never do that right
right they get excited yeah and then
they retain clients also yeah and listen
a bunch believe a do it personally
I'm just telling you that's firm yeah
yeah not as much in the net result right
exactly it's the number one mistake that
every single professional service like
provider kind of like company's making
right now they're trying to put the
internet back in the box I'll try to
make you rock the most famous I turned
him into a [ __ ] verb and now so so
this is back to like actions over you
know yeah you know words I believe in it
the Oh
yeah it's something we're really
committed it's something I'm not natural
to the industry yeah that's for sure
salons don't want their people like they
all they suppress yea they suppress up
and like stand into their light yeah you
will have disproportionate funnel yeah
like you should I think out of all
things I'm like we're talking here a
little bit the the one hour and these
two things like look a young company is
about decisions yep it's about decisions
like when I think about Boehner it was
like making the decision to like make a
lot of social media content is why we're
sitting here today in the form that we
are yeah right
like deciding that I had to have big
time media capabilities when I started
to sense any kind of organic reach drop
like there's decisions like hiring only
friends at first because I wanted a
culture of that like these like these
meanings like you know there's there's a
real reason Phil takes you know two
thousand meetings a year it's because
after I was doing them back in the day a
lot of people want did them all the time
and that didn't scale for me these are
important decisions yeah and you have to
be very thoughtful about what you lean
into like like for example if you
thought I was right and you do lean into
building out then that takes time and
effort yeah yeah that's that's strategy
that's you not thinking about you or the
customer that's talking about the most
important asset but it could become so
disruptive it could be the game changer
and so defensible against are their
competitors in a way that's funny
because you're vulnerable right that's
your strength yeah I like that
why'd you like it so much because I
think you know knowing you it's a little
bit of a curveball yeah for me of what
like I'm curious myself like why I'm
being serious in a real way right it
ever launched yet it's it's it's
physical locations which I like the
practicality of that a lot I'm a buyer
of the payback period just curious
belief that they can pull off of
experience that's next level just
interacting with them spending time with
them yeah
from what I've learned over the years
and I guess pattern matching the fact
that there is whitespace there selling
time and just the brand resonates with
me I just like them as people - yeah I
think that's just gonna carry through
the globe our brand their dynamic are
investing in us because of who we are
because like we have no revenues oh we
have adapt and we have the mic there's
only two things of course yeah they're
you know the first round of capital is
always people an idea you know there is
nothing else yeah and we think we've
been really thoughtful about creating
something special and focused on the
consumer and what they need right now
and I think that's like a winning
strategy if you ask me like the
forefront of our minds with every single
decision we ask ourselves is this
helping her take better care of her skin
than she is today and we like have heard
from almost every female we've
interacted with that there is something
more she could be doing but she just
doesn't know what and so knowing that
that need is there and the fact that
we're building to solve that is what
kind of really motivates us what do you
think happens in a recession what's your
intuition do you have any data on what
happened to the space in the oh wait oh
nine I think one of the things that's
running through my mind is timing yeah
obviously this is a luxury ish I mean
seventy bucks it's it's a luxury but I
understand a necessity back to dentist
versus rye bar right how much or how
little or what do you think happens when
the bottom falls out yeah so traditional
beauty so back in late 2008 when like
the recession hit beauty actually like
stayed afloat because it was a small
little luxury that they look lipstick
wasn't look thick during the Great
Depression that I understand right
that's a little bit different than when
you're talking that we are because the
average is 150 dollars and we're only 70
I think it will still to some in some
markets still be considered a more
affordable accessible price point that
they can still treat themselves that's
right I mean I think I think it's right
I think you could lose a lot of people
yeah I think what I wonder consistency
yeah I think the question is can you
gain enough from the 150s that need to
go to 70 yeah
I think it's a the demographic we're
going after actually helps a little bit
we think that like they are used to
seeing that 150 and then they'll come to
70 and then are you worried about people
valuing something based on price golf
has I've been a discussion yeah there's
like we're having a focus group for
pricing actually just to make sure that
we're hitting that like now I'm ahead
with it and just like going through a
few scenarios of like how
psychologically people are reacting to
the $70 price point with the product
that we're providing because we're
actually providing the value is similar
to the hundred and fifty it's just we've
been able to cut out all the fluff and
make it for $70 have you thought about
the basic like retail principle of
making it 69 or 79 just cuz its I know I
know I know
like I thought about that don't be don't
be a dirtbag
you know the nine bothers you more than
like the silly reference you know like a
visual of not let me let me save you a
lot of respect we have talked about oh
they're like oh yeah be like something I
would tell you what I would pay I would
run Google ads against search queries
and run a bunch of testing and Facebook
ads like do what Tim Ferriss Brit Louie
did for our work week was a beta test on
Google searches I would run Facebook
Instagram and Google ads against pricing
of a fake salon landing page and see who
signs up for what and why I think so and
I think that we live in 2019 and you
guys can literally not kidding here's
what I would do if I were you I would
create a fake ID fake facial place the
mistress and call Gary's if he like you
should test create some one-off landing
pages run ads against certain demos and
income levels see what people react to
get their email right yeah and then send
a surprise gift to everybody
as like an announcement for what you're
launching seven weeks ago you filmed out
you know like something get out of me so
that'd be fun you're surprising
delighting them yeah you're getting
information win-win-win-win-win yeah and
for like five hundred bucks of Instagram
and Facebook ads you're getting a real
meaningful weed yeah that's okay yeah
consider it done it's helpful let me
know how when we will we will cuz you're
gonna see it carry singles not launching
in New York
anything else again a for me um so many
things what do you think what do you
think of the rest of this business
I am very obsessed with the time saving
thing okay it's my number one thesis I
think that I think I think you're in the
branding business I think that if you're
right you're gonna have a lot of fast
followers and a lot of people adjusting
and then that goes away so I think
you're in the branding business yeah I
really do I'm that which is why I'm so
disproportionately excited about you
building up what are they called again I
apologize as decisions
I think the esthetician things exciting
to me because building a brand that
you're Pro that is going to be a
leverage point over time yeah like
tomorrow if I have for facial places in
Long Island and you're getting real
traction and I'm like [ __ ] and like and
obviously there's things in process that
allows you to do in 30 it's it's it's
something that will be moved if you're
right it gets moved on pretty quickly
yeah and I think like building out brand
and being loud and proud is important
yeah yeah when so like similar to that
when you think about our marketing and
kind of what you've heard a little bit
what's sort of your reaction to that of
like really focusing on like earned
media and like focusing on our products
in the beginning versus running
billboards and Facebook ads for our
brand people don't know yet I would do
what you're doing
I'd probably layer influencer marketing
on top yeah okay yeah billboard no
Facebook yeah but I would do influencer
marketing okay I would also call in
favors yeah I mean I think you like find
out the most fabulous girls you have in
your rolodex at the school with friends
homies ourselves respect that's only two
and so like I really do think
more friends and family upfront yeah but
like friends and family with like a
requirement of like that's nice
we're giving it to you we're not giving
it to you unless you post on your
Instagram right of course and I'll
create organic growth yeah I think you
manipulate the organic growth a little
bit up front through influencers that
you pay and listen you know what I don't
like about the startup community yet
like not yet like in its current form
it's not desperate enough yeah I'm
coming
that's why I come back money being
completely out of control on this
director consumer wine brand I launched
I'm hustling and grinding and being so
ghetto and I have all the leverage and
money yeah and I'm still doing it cuz
it's my natural state it's a new baby
like this is where you like swallow
pride and like email some girl that like
didn't say something nice about you but
doesn't know that you'd know and still
ask her to do it because it's good for
your [ __ ] business
yeah yeah yeah we definitely are gonna
get scrappy do you understand that I
know that they're gonna do that and
that's another reason they're here I
thought that I actually want to show you
your part was done with it I want to
show you I don't know if I'm gonna be
able to find it you were asked the
question find this fast enough but we
have like a great campaign it's super
scrappy for like telephone poles like
scratching your guerilla marketing
campaign each that you've had your whole
life versus versus yes Tyler I gotta go
cool versus influence our [ __ ]
marketing and like most fab girls you
know call in favors yeah annoying yeah
okay be annoying really listen the cool
thing is it's like me when I'm gonna be
annoying when the actual rose' comes out
I'm gonna be annoying to tell people I
want to send them a bottle or Jose to
take a picture and put on Instagram but
they can drink it like being annoying
again like like and you need a mix right
you oh you need Instagram gal that's got
a big following that's with but like you
know like somebody you were friends with
that like fancy like you know
consulting firm who's got 1700 but she's
Alfa Scarsdale matters too
yeah yeah hi-low yeah yeah sure really a
freezing measure so great meeting you
can we get one pic with you
you sure can just so latest one we have
proof cuz I feel like our family thanks
for lying
hey I'm Phil Toronto SVP of special
projects with Gary we just wrapped our
meeting with Rachel and a high of globe
our if you want to follow along in their
opening journey you can follow them on
Instagram at glow bar or sign up for
their newsletter at get globe are calm
[Music]